[Music]
[Applause]
two-time World Series champ with the Red
Sox and managing the Dodgers manager of
the year he's Dave Roberts who joins us
now Dodgers are 14 and a half games
ahead of Arizona in the National League
West so you get a luxury there Dave but
I'm wondering we see sometimes where
teams who take that time off rest
players they get into the postseason
they're not ready for postseason
baseball so if you had your druthers if
you were up by one and a half instead of
14 and a half or you won your division
by one and a half instead of 14 and a
half does that change how your team
would play in the postseason
um you know what I don't think so Dan I
I think that uh you know I think that
it's I think it's one of those things
that people look at certain narratives
and things and I'm sure there's many
times where teams go wire to wire and
finish out well and other times where
they go wire to wire they're gassed and
they run out of steam
um so I I do think that last year I
think we had six or seven days that was
uh quite excessive I think this year
we've got five days and we're gonna try
to do as much as we can to simulate
um but yeah it's one of those things
that we get a chance to rest uh Bullpen
guys players and and get them ready but
yeah try not to lose that uh that edge
that we had going into uh the postseason
how much football do you watch
so uh truth be told uh the last eight
years I didn't watch any football I'm a
huge football fan
um but just the job the undertaking
um you know it's something uh buddy
black was a mentor of mine and he used
to get them get under his skin when guys
are watching football on Saturdays and
Sundays so I try to have base I do have
baseball on but this is the first year
in I think 20 years that I'm back in
fantasy football so I'm uh watching a
little bit more uh suffice to say
is it a team fantasy or a family Fantasy
League
so there's a team fantasy that the guys
have I'm in a family old school Friends
League that I've had for Jesus I mean
goes back probably 30 years and uh
tyreek's carrying you right now who's
your quarterback
uh I've got uh Russell Wilson and Gino
um Geno Smith okay
do you okay I'm three and one so I'm I'm
okay I'm okay right now okay but how do
you stay away from football football
finds you you can't stay away for eight
years
uh uh you know what I did I did
um yeah I stayed away from football
um I don't know how I did it but I'm
glad I'm back and I I like I told you
Dan you know football's My First Love
yeah I know uh can you take anything
away from other sports or what do you
take away from other sports that you can
put into play as manager of the Dodgers
um you know what I've had a great
opportunity
um to get to know other coaches uh from
other sports
and um I I think the thing that we've
all kind of
come to agreement on is that it's hard
the job's hard
um and we spend a lot of time pouring
into players uh what do I take from
these guys I think that we're sort of
all in the same fraternity
um of loving coaching players and and I
think that's something I wouldn't say
anything that's really more tangible as
far as x's and o's outside the fact that
we just love the game that we coach and
love teaching players when's the last
time you yelled at a player
the last time I yelled at a player was
probably uh 2016 and it was a Yasiel
Puig and I love that y'all but it was
free yeah
he felt that because he didn't start uh
it was an off day and when he was called
to pinch it he wasn't too excited about
it
wow sometimes I don't know if if you
approach your players the way you do
your children then if I have a my voice
is lower and I'm not yelling my message
gets through a whole lot better than if
I'm animated
oh absolutely and that's the way I go
about things uh in general it's one of
those things that you know as a coach
you you sometimes uh early on you don't
understand you can't match the players
uh sort of uh intensity passion and uh
as you coach longer and longer you learn
to take a deep breath and defuse
which works better as you said we're
talking to Dave Roberts Dodger manager
it's Dodgers at the Rockies today
that'll be uh first pitch 3 10 Eastern
what do you remember about Deion Sanders
the baseball player
so Deion Sanders a baseball player I
remember
um
the Braves I remember the the triple to
the poolside Gap
um and how quick he got to uh third base
um I remember the Jerry curl the gold
chains
um playing in a a football game and then
going and playing in a playoff baseball
game
can you remember somebody who had
anywhere near that speed
no no I think that different type of
speed I remember Bo Jackson
um but it was you know
230 pounds of brute strength and muscle
but Dion was different uh that type of
electricity and you know I just don't
recall a football team
um a football player taking away a half
of a half of the field like Dion did
when he played if they just played
baseball who do you think would have had
a better career Beau or Dion
if they just played baseball I think
Beau had a better career I think beau's
ability to really really defend
um with the plus plus arm and then the
power the speed he would have been a
better baseball player no matter what
Dion says
as far as the rules this year the pitch
clock didn't turn out to be as big a
deal
uh would you say that's that's fair
no it didn't it wasn't a big deal at all
I think that sometimes you know players
have the ability to adapt and uh this is
just completely evident this year and
it's actually a much better game I think
Major League Baseball got it right uh
the pace of play
um the without the shift and you see now
plays in the six hole you see uh players
uh you know you saw the other day mookie
making great plays
um in that in that game against uh the
Giants where if there was a shift that
wouldn't have happened so you're getting
to see athleticism two and a half hour
game is much more watchable so it's just
a better product overall
yeah I I think it uh at first I thought
okay is it going to be tougher for the
hitters or the pitchers and I I don't
know would you say like did you have to
have a meeting with pitchers more or
hitters more with the pitch clock
both both because uh you know Clayton
Kershaw for example he works quick
doesn't affect him but there's other
guys that take uh time in between
pitches and it is going to be
interesting uh you know in the
postseason where I do think the build up
the timing between pitches is more as it
gets late it was supposed season
um keep an eye on that uh but the
hitters also it's like sometimes they
like to step out kind of regroup but I
think now that like I said they've all
calibrated they stay in the box and it's
quicker and the rhythm is just much more
bet it's just much better and the stolen
base is back
how do you feel about that and the
stolen bases back uh which is great the
bigger bases those uh Pizza carts I
think that no one notices anymore again
Dan it's just a more Dynamic game that's
what everyone wanted uh that's what we
got you get to see great athletes and
and I'll tell you this is that baseball
is starting to get market share with
athletes you know in the last you know
call it 10 to 15 uh years football
basketball I've taken it but I'm telling
you watch out baseball is going to start
getting the market share on great
athletes I ask it every year the Dodgers
will win the World Series if
oh Dan no you're not gonna get me this
year
if everything lines up the last time you
did it you won Dave
yeah but no because then you don't I say
the pitching doesn't stay healthy the
Dodgers will win if everything lines up
and we play good baseball how about that
get a little luck come on don't go there
Dan you know
nice try buddy just guarantee it just
guarantee it
right you're not worried about the
bridge you're not worried about the
Braves are you
oh I know I know be careful I'm gonna
ask you about ohtani
yeah I'll see some questions
well hopefully uh it's a long time
before we get to that off season uh
question uh great to talk to you and uh
thanks again for joining us
all right take care dad and don't get
thrown out today all right
no we got we got two today in Colorado
so uh if today today would be a good day
actually
to get thrown out of the first one
absolutely I hope it does into the
second one are you allowed to leave the
building like could you go to dinner
after if you got thrown out early
I think I could I haven't I just uh hang
on the office and have a couple Pops
that sounds pretty good to me thank you
Dave
all right Dad that's Dave Roberts Dodger
manager by the way his wine it's called
Red Stitch got another great review by
wine spectator and Wine Enthusiast he
never bring he never asked me to mention
that but he has some great wines there
that he's part of